soberanía y liderazgo europeo un
objetivo que la presidenta de la
comisión úrsula von der leyen ha fijado
en distintos ámbitos sanitario
humanitario económico militar
honorables diputados es hora de que
europa pase a un nivel superior en el
discurso del estado de la unión la
presidenta del ejecutivo europeo ha
anunciado 50 mil millones de euros de
financiación para evitar una nueva
pandemia celebro que el 70% de la
población europea haya sido totalmente
vacunada aunque subrayó las brechas
entre distintos estados además anunció
la donación de 200 millones de vacunas a
países pobres respondiendo así a los
reproches de la o ms que critica la
política de las terceras dosis en países
ricos
por otro lado von der leyen celebró el
crecimiento económico europeo que podría
alcanzar sus niveles pre pandemia en los
27 estados para finales de 2022 grow in
the air
el crecimiento en la zona euro ha
superado el de eeuu y el de china en el
último trimestre de ese sound y tienen
pero esto es sólo el principio y las
lecciones de la crisis financiera
podrían servirnos de advertencia frente
a la dependencia tecnológica de china y
a la militar de la otan la respuesta es
una apuesta por la soberanía europea por
un lado con producción masiva de
semiconductores avanzados y por el otro
tras la crisis de afganistán relanzando
con fuerza la idea de una unidad militar
europea para poder intervenir sin
depender del liderazgo estadounidense
'george kim hyunjoon anteriores la unión
europea y los estados unidos siempre
serán más fuertes juntos pero la unión
europea puede claramente debe ser capaz
y querer hacer más por sí misma you to
work on its own la comisión promete 100
millones de euros adicionales para
paliar la crisis humanitaria en
afganistán y en los países vecinos pero
no habla de los refugiados que están o
estarán en europa en situación irregular